je pense que les tests pcr sont fred
nécessaire ou au moins une assez bonne
idée en dans la limite des moyens parce
que ça coûte sûrement un peu cher je
sais en france c'est gratuit mais dans
d'autres pays ça doit ça peut peut-être
peut être trop cher pour certaines
personnes
globalement l'isolément à sept jours
pour moi c'est quelque chose dogme tant
qu'on n'a pas vraiment d'idée sur plus
précises sur le fonctionnement de ces de
ces variants et sur leur niveau
d'infection zitte et ça me paraît
justifié de les traiter de la même
manière qu'eux on traite les autres les
autres les autres patients les autres
cas contacts qui ont pu très avoir un
contact avec ce virus vous arrivez à
l'aéroport de roissy aucun contrôle je
peux vous dire ok même si vous arrivez
des pays contaminés ça aurait peut-être
évité un peu le l'entrée du virus fait
du mutant britannique
ah oui je pense que c'est important de
pouvoir généraliser cette pratique
au vu des flux migratoires de tout ce
qui se passe en europe je pense que
c'est ça serait bénéfique pour pouvoir
endiguer l'épidémie
je pense que oui ça c'est une contrainte
supplémentaire mais ça devient
nécessaire de pouvoir contrôler les gens
qui arrivent en france et qui en sortent
de manier et de même chose pour les
autres pays ça sera pas facile à mettre
en place quoi c'est hors europe et en
europe à un groupe union européenne
voilà oui oui moi je pense que oui c'est
quand même le président parce que tout
ce qui se baladent c'est plus peut-être
plus efficaces et les problèmes de
logistique en france pensent que nous
sommes des spécialistes la non
organisation
il est vrai que le gouvernement a été
très surpris également mais je pense
qu'on aurait pu anticiper par rapport à
déjà ce qui se passait en chine
pas forcément non je dirais plutôt pour
éventuellement un passeport pour les
gens qui arrivent en 30
mais sinon voulait mettre pendant sept
jours c'est très compliqué de contrôler
les gens donc non je pense qu'il vaut
mieux une formalité mais sur papier
c'est à dire qu'ils aient suivi en test
éventuellement quand ils rentrent qui
montrent leur papier c'est tout ça dans
un monde la mêlée si on ne peut pas
contrôler les sept jours c'est encore
plus grave au point de vue sanitaire
eh bien peut-être or les mettons en
place en 6 personnes à à l'hôtel et puis
voilà quelles qu'elles soient confinés
dans un endroit
/ ou en fait il ya possibilité de les
suivre complètement oui je suis tout à
fait favorable d'ailleurs il ya d'autres
pays qui le pratiquent
je m'intéresse un peu au tennis soit
l'australie c'est ce qu'il pratique avec
les joueurs qui viennent
hier l'open d'australie en france je
vois pas pourquoi on pourrait pas le
faire il ya des infrastructures
l'hôtellerie aujourd'hui n'a plus de
touristes donc on pourrait utiliser
toute cette infrastructure et ça procure
est entre autres des clients peut-être
forcée mais les clients pour
l'hôtellerie française
c'est une très bonne idée dans le sens
où ça va permettre de réguler le grenat
virus et de pas ne pas prendre des
personnes qui sont attendues coronavirus
en france enfin c'est peut-être c'est un
investissement qui est assez important
mais au final ça sera sera très efficace
pour limiter la propagation du corps